The Hulk may be one of Marvel's most famous
heroes, but after the release of The Incredible
Hulk, Bruce Banner was sidelined until The
Avengers rolled around four years later.
And even then, the Hulk's role in the MCU
has largely been a supporting one.
So why did we never get to see The Incredible
Hulk 2?
When The MCU began, their core actors were
in place: Chris Evans as Captain America.
Chris Hemsworth playing Thor.
And of course Robert Downey Jr., nailing the
role of Iron Man.
Well, three out of four isn’t bad, because
we all know what happened with Bruce Banner.
So why did Edward Norton fail to make the
cut for Earth's mightiest heroes?
While most of the actors playing Avengers
have had a long and prosperous relationship
with Marvel Studios, Norton seems to have
gotten off on the wrong foot from day one.
In fact, he doesn't appear to have even been
the first choice for the role.
In an interview with the Huffington Post,
director Louis Leterrier let it slip that,
while he appreciated what Norton brought to
the table, his first pick had actually been
Mark Ruffalo.
"I prefer you."
On top of his runner-up status, numerous rumors
have arisen over the years suggesting that
Norton may have been difficult to work with
on the set, that he was "very vocal" at times
when he disagreed with something, and that
he was overly involved in tampering with the
script.
While none of these are particularly rare
qualities in Hollywood stars, they're not
likely to stack the deck in your favor, either.
It didn't take long after the film came out
for the first hints of discord to begin surfacing.
Two years after The Incredible Hulk's release,
Marvel boss Kevin Feige made the announcement
that Norton would not be brought back to "portray
the title role of Bruce Banner in The Avengers."
At the time, Feige insisted that the decision
wasn't a monetary one.
His statement read:
"Our decision is definitely not one based
on monetary factors, but instead rooted in
the need for an actor who embodies the creativity
and collaborative spirit of our other talented
cast members."
Feige's statement made it clear that something
had been going on behind closed doors something
more than a few friendly disagreements over
the script.
Luckily, the Hulk was still set to appear
in the first Avengers movie and would continue
to make appearances in other characters' future
films.
But the removal of Norton from the role shed
a little light on why Iron Man, played by
the immensely popular Robert Downey Jr., became
the center of a burgeoning franchise while
the Hulk languished on the sidelines.
Norton's agent was quick to respond to Feige's
statement.
In his rebuttal, he said:
"This offensive statement from Kevin Feige
at Marvel is a purposefully misleading, inappropriate
attempt to paint our client in a negative
light."
The actor himself took to social media, not
to attack Marvel, but rather to express his
disappointment at the way things had turned
out.
He wrote:
"I sincerely hoped it could happen and be
great for everyone, but it hasn't turned out
as we all hoped.
I know this is disappointing to many people
and that makes me sad.
But I am very sincerely grateful to Marvel
for extending the offer and even more so for
giving me the chance to be a part of the Hulk's
long and excellent history."
These responses from Norton and his agent
seemed to indicate that, no matter how bad
things might have been behind the scenes,
Norton had continued to hope that he would
reprise his role.
Unfortunately, Feige's decision put an end
to those hopes.
As the dust settled, Norton eventually traded
his regretful tune for one of indifference,
explaining a few years later that he had lost
interest in the role, and instead wanted to
act in other movies and genres.
While it's been rumored for years that Norton
isn't the easiest person to work with, that
doesn't mean the blame for his removal deserves
to fall squarely on his Hulked-out shoulders.
Both Marvel Studios and Disney have developed
a track record over the years for dismissing
various personnel who haven't fallen in line
with their vision.
For example, Thor: The Dark World's first
director, Patty Jenkins, said she didn't think
she "could make a great film out of their
script."
Rather than allowing her to adjust the story,
the studio parted ways with the director…
who went on to head up Wonder Woman, while
Marvel ended up with a subpar sequel to their
Thor franchise.
Terrence Howard also infamously lost the role
of James "Rhodey" Rhodes to Don Cheadle after
Iron Man.
And of course, there's Guardians of the Galaxy
franchise mastermind James Gunn, who was fired
in 2018 after internet users dug up some of
his old and quite offensive tweets.
While Disney may have ultimately reinstated
Gunn to his previous position, the whole Norton
debacle wasn't the only behind the scenes
misstep Marvel Studios has endured.
Although the actual details of the behind-the-scenes
breakup may never be cleared up, however,
one thing that was crystal clear as the door
swung shut on Norton: the Hulk's MCU storyline
wasn't going anywhere fast.
Rights are a tricky business in Hollywood.
In the case of a standalone Hulk sequel, though,
they're even more nuanced than usual.
While Sony may own the rights to Spider-Man,
for example, the rights to Hulk are more or
less "split" between Marvel and Universal.
But unlike the innovative time-sharing agreement
between Sony and Marvel for Spidey, the Hulk's
situation has been complicated by the less-than-stellar
relationship between the two studios holding
the strings.
According to Forbes, Marvel regained the rights
to the Hulk character in 2005 when Universal
neglected to pursue a sequel to Ang Lee's
2003 movie Hulk.
"So, they think they can just throw you away
as they did me."
But while that meant Marvel were given the
chance to integrate Hulk into their cinematic
universe, Universal retained one critical
piece of the puzzle: the "right of first refusal"
over the distribution of any solo Hulk films.
In other words, while Marvel can use the Hulk
character, if they decide to make a Hulk movie,
Universal gets first dibs on distributing
the feature.
Of course, Marvel has used other studios to
distribute their movies before, and the lack
of distribution rights alone isn't enough
of a reason to put the kibosh on a sequel.
But considering all the other issues The Incredible
Hulk faced during production and after its
release, it can't have helped things much,
either.
It's easy to look at the quarter of a billion
that The Incredible Hulk made in theaters
and dismiss money as a motivation in Marvel's
hesitation to produce a sequel.
But the numbers are actually a bit of an issue.
Even though the movie was released before
the days when Marvel was pumping out billion-dollar
projects a couple of times a year, the film
still underperformed at the box office.
During its run, Norton's Hulk brought in $263,427,551
which is a respectable sum, to say the least.
But take Iron Man for comparison.
That movie, which was released just a few
months prior to The Incredible Hulk and which
cost $10 million less to make brought in twice
as much in global ticket sales.
And while The Incredible Hulk may not have
been a complete flop, its less-than-stellar
box office performance and middling critical
reception likely suggested to Marvel that
the Hulk alone just isn't compelling enough
to draw a big crowd.
Having the Hulk show up for a handful of epic
fight scenes is exactly the kind of integration
that makes his presence in Marvel's more recent
films worthwhile.
But the truth is, it costs a lot to produce
a whole film centered on a completely CGI
character and that goes doubly when any scene
they're in is going to have to include a kitchen
sink's worth of flying cars, crumbling buildings,
and all kinds of mayhem.
While a huge investment in special effects
is part and parcel of bigger crossover releases
like the Avengers movies, an entire film of
that nature focused on a single character
is a daunting task to expect a studio to take
on.
And when you take into consideration the disappointing
box office reception of The Incredible Hulk,
it becomes that much easier to believe that
the Marvel and studio execs involved in the
decision would hesitate before signing off
on such an expensive project.
Although the snowball effect of subpar ticket
sales, uninspired reviews, production costs,
behind the scenes drama, and distribution
rights would have already been more than enough
to put the final nail in the coffin of any
Hulk sequel, that's not the end of the story.
In many ways, the true Achilles heel of the
Hulk's one and only MCU outing was that it
simply failed to fit the tone of the wider
MCU.
Whether it was the solemn introspection that
Norton tried to bring to the role or the inherent
difficulties in exploring the Hulk's mindless
destruction as the centerpiece of a story,
The Incredible Hulk ended up struggling to
hit the effortlessly entertaining tone of
most of the following MCU films.
Taking place in Phase One of the MCU, Hulk's
film was set against characters like the selfishly
sarcastic Tony Stark, the lovably loyal Steve
Rogers and the hilariously hunky Thor all
of whom were busy setting the stage for the
first Avengers movie.
In comparison, Hulk's more serious overtones
stood out like a big, green sore thumb and
made the film dark enough to dampen the enthusiasm
of even the most ardent Marvel fan.
As if the sobering tone of the film wasn't
enough, there's also the fact that the story
started by dropping the audience into a random
spot in Banner and the Hulk's story arc and
then proceeded to take it absolutely nowhere.
After skipping over the famous gamma radiation
exposure incident, the film proceeded to meander
awkwardly through Banner's harrowingly unheroic
adventures.
He finally flashed a little superhero muscle
when he subdued Abomination in the streets
of Harlem, but when the film ended shortly
after things once again took a step backward.
Banner's takeaway from the experience was
simply that he had found a way to come to
terms with the Other Guy.
And while this appeared to be a positive step
forward for the character, the fact that it
was quickly retconned when Ruffalo's distressed
Banner was brought back on the scene in The
Avengers made the whole point of the film
pretty much... pointless.
In July 2017, Mark Ruffalo predicted that,
quote, "a standalone Hulk movie will never
happen."
And while that may have seemed like the end
of the story, you could argue that a secret
Incredible Hulk follow-up already exists.
"Hulk!
Hulk!
Hulk!"
Around the same time that Ruffalo dashed fans'
hopes of ever seeing another solo Hulk film,
the actor also revealed in another interview
that he'd sat down with Kevin Feige and the
two had brainstormed what a standalone film
for the Hulk would look like.
Once they had a good idea to work from, they
decided to implement it into the wider MCU
by divvying up the story across three separate
movies.
Cleverly, none of these would be released
as a standalone film, thus sidestepping the
rights issue with Universal.
Instead, the Hulk storyline would be woven
through Thor: Ragnarok, Avengers: Infinity
War, and Avengers: Endgame, during which his
"sequel storyline" could finally be told one
piece at a time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.